Okay.
Hallo, Schönen guten Tag.
Mein Name ist Frau Bayrak.
Ich bin auf die Sichtation ASAS der Nasden tätig
und würde gerne mit Ihnen das Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Bitte unterbrechen Sie mir,
wann Sie etwas nicht verstehen oder wann Sie Fragen haben.
Ja.
Okay, ja.
Bevor Sie mir Ihre Beschwerden nassen,
würde ich gerne ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Wie halten Sie?
Ich müsste ein bisschen langsamer sprechen,
sonst habe ich Schwierigkeiten, in die zu verstehen.
Entschuldigung, natürlich.
Wie halten Sie bitte?
Also mein Name ist Rainer Kovaman.
Rainer Kovaman.
Ja.
Rainer R-A-I-N-E-R.
Und Kovaman K-O-V-O-M-A-N.
E-R-K-O-V-E-R-Mann.
C-O-K-O-V-E-R und ein Mann.
Ja, ich habe verstanden.
Danke schön.
Und wer sind Sie?
Ich bin 52 Jahre.
52, wann sind Sie genau geboren?
Am 20.09.1972.
20.09.1972.
Ja, Frau Kovaman.
Herr Kovaman, wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 1870.
1870.
Und wie schwer sind Sie?
Ich wiege 88 kg.
88 kg?
Ja.
Frau Kovaman, was fühlt sich so aus?
Wie kann ich Ihnen helfen?
Ach, wissen Sie, ich habe seit ein paar Tagen
Schmerzen in der rechten Wade.
Und es wird irgendwie immer mehr.
Und ja, das ist mir so ein bisschen unheimlich.
Ich habe eine längere Flugreise gemacht,
war also viele Stunden unterwegs.
Und das war vor vier Tagen.
Und jetzt ist es aber immer schlimmer geworden.
Und das Bein ist auch so ein bisschen rot und geschwollen.
Und jetzt habe ich gedacht, jetzt komme ich doch mal lieber schnell
notfallmäßig in die Klinik.
Ja.
Okay, seit ein paar Tagen haben Sie im Wade Schmerzen
und Sie haben eine Langgäder-Flügeisergärme gemacht.
Und viele Stunden waren Sie unterwechst
und Ihre Wadenbereich rote, hafaber hat und geschwollen.
Ja, genau.
Und es schmerzt auch wirklich sehr.
Ja.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kompressionstrumpfe benutzt in diesem Reise?
Nein, habe ich nicht. Nein.
Ja. Und jetzt haben Sie Luftnot.
Luftnot habe ich nicht.
Nein, das Bein tut mir weh.
Ja, okay.
Und haben Sie Fieber?
Fieber? Ich habe mich nicht gemessen.
Nein, nein, ich wollte das nur eben abklären.
Wissen Sie, ich habe viel zu tun.
Ich habe viel Arbeit und und ja, der Firma ist viel los.
Also ich muss jetzt nur eben schauen, dass da nichts ist.
Und dann muss ich wieder los.
Wo sind die?
Wo sind diese Schmerzen? Wo sind die genauer Schmerzen?
Ja, die sind überwiegend in der Wade und strahlen so ein bisschen ins Knie hoch.
Ein bisschen Knie.
Lechter oder linke Seite oder?
Auf der rechten Seite.
Rechten Seite, Knie erst.
Okay.
Und rot und geschwollen.
Ja.
Und haben Sie Probleme beim Laufen?
Ja, beim Laufen tut es natürlich mehr weh, wenn ich das hochlege.
Das habe ich jetzt die Tage, habe ich so ein bisschen geschont
und auch bei der Arbeit mit so einem Hocker unterschreibt, das ist gestellt.
Aber sobald ich ein bisschen rumlaufe, tut es eigentlich wieder mehr weh.
Und jetzt ist es halt immer schlimmer geworden.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und?
Ähm.
Rauchen Sie?
Ich rauche ja.
Ja, ja.
Aha.
Wie viele ist der Tag?
Rauchen Sie?
Ach, so ein Päckchen am Tag ist das schon.
Ähm, 20 20.
20 Stück kann man sagen, so ungefähr.
Seit wann?
Boch.
Seit ich erwachsen war, ja, war halt das auch mit 22 habe ich angefangen.
Also, ja, 30 Jahre jetzt.
Okay.
Ja.
Und?
Äh, jetzt.
Okay.
Jetzt, ich frage Ihnen ein paar allgemeine Fragen.
Haben Sie Fristen?
Nein, Husten habe ich nicht.
Mhm.
Okay.
Und gibt es etwas, das die Schmerzen verschlimmert oder lindert, außer dann Bewegung?
Ja, wie gesagt, wenn man es so ein bisschen hochlegt aus Beinen, dann ist es ein bisschen besser.
Aber wie gesagt, im Gehen ist es schlechter.
Sonst wüsste ich jetzt nicht, was ich noch besser machen könnte.
Mhm.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhafter oder gehen Sie auch wieder weg?
Nee, die sind eigentlich die ganze Zeit da und es drückt und wird eben auch immer mehr.
Deswegen bin ich jetzt auch in den gekommen, weil es immer schlechter wurde.
Am Anfang denkt man dir immer, ja, ist es von alleine gekommen, geht auch wieder von alleine weg.
Aber nee, das ist ja nicht.
Ja, und drücken.
Ja.
Drücken, ja, es drückt ganz toll, ja, genau.
Und, ähm,
Wichtags sind die Schmerzen auf eines Skalophon 1 bis 10, wobei 1 ist der
leichte und 10 ist der starken Schmerz nicht.
War, das sind schon kräftige Schmerzen, also.
Über die Hälfte, mindestens, sagen wir bei 6, so würde ich sagen.
6.
Okay.
Ja.
Äh, ja, okay.
Haben Sie Schweißausbrüche?
Scheiße, Scheißausbrüche habe ich nicht.
Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Ja.
Jetzt, äh, ich frage ein paar allgemeine Fragen, stellen, äh, ich werde ein paar allgemeine Fragen stellen.
Haben Sie Probleme, wie Dämmstuhlgang oder beim Musterlassen?
Ja, also ich habe manchmal ein bisschen Verstopfung, aber wissen Sie bei meinem
Lebensfall, ich bin eben sehr viel unterwegs und bin auch oft auf Reisen und da kommt man
manchmal nicht so dazu.
Also da habe ich manchmal ein bisschen Probleme, ja.
Mhm.
Nimmens, sehe einen Apfel, Mitteil ein dagegen.
Ja, also wenn, wenn mal so gar nichts mehr geht, dann nehme ich auch mal einen Apfel,
bitte ein, aber das ist nur ganz selten.
Mhm, ganz selten.
Mhm.
Ja, okay.
Und ähm, schlafen Sie gut?
Ja, das kommt drauf an, also ähm, eigentlich, eigentlich schlafe ich nicht so gut, manchmal
eben wegen Stress, weil so viel los ist in der Firma und natürlich auch diese, diese
Langstreckenflüge immer irgendwie andere Zeitzonen und so.
Das merke ich dann schon, äh, wenn ich dann so den, den Jetlag hab, dann kann ich nicht
gut schlafen, dann bin ich aus dem Takt.
Also schlafen ist nicht so gut.
Mhm.
Ähm, was ist das für ein Beruf?
Was ist das für eine?
Das ist für eine, das ist für eine Industriefirma.
Ja.
Und sie haben viel Stress.
Oh ja, wir haben ja, sie wissen ja die Zeiten, die Wirtschaft und nicht.
Und wir müssen uns alle nach der Decke strecken und wir müssen gucken, die
Arbeitsplätze zu erhalten und ja.
Und sie sagen, sie können nicht gut schlafen, weil Jetlag und Stress
nehmen sie dagegen ein, die wegen der Schlafprobleme.
Manchmal trinke ich abends mal ein Glas Wein oder so, aber normalerweise nehme
ich eigentlich nichts zum Einschlafen.
Aber Wein häst zum Schlafen, ne?
Auch nicht wirklich, ja.
Es schmeckt nur gut, ja.
Okay.
Auch nicht.
Ja, okay.
Und ähm, außer dann haben sie Hüsten.
Hüsten habe ich, habe ich ein, ja, manchmal habe ich so ein bisschen trocknen Hüsten,
aber also jetzt heute nicht besonders.
Und ja.
Und ich merke das auch, also ich bin nicht mehr so fit wie früher.
Wenn ich also schnell die Treppe hochlaufe oder wenn ich schnell mit
meinem Koffer irgendwo hinlaufen muss.
Hü, da komme ich doch ein bisschen in die Hüsten, ja.
Sie füllen sich nicht national wie früher.
Ist das heutzutage oder wegen dieser Beinschmerzen?
Nein, das ist, nee, das ist schon länger so, das ist schon länger so,
dass ich merke, dass ich mehr so fit bin, ja.
Haben Sie Herz-Kranzprobleme oder Herzprobleme?
Nicht, dass ich wüsste.
Ja, ich wüsste.
Okay.
Jetzt gucken wir Ihre Vorgeschichte.
Haben Sie, manche Vorerkrankungen von der Nivelle,
haben Sie, manche Vorerkrankungen von denen ich wissen sollte,
zum Beispiel Zuckerkrankheit oder Bullutochtdruck?
Also ich habe ein bisschen hohen Blutdruck, ja, das ist schon klar.
Mhm, sagt man.
Ach, das hat man schon vor langer Zeit
festgestellt, das ist bestimmt schon 15 Jahre.
15 Jahre.
Aha, was nehmen Sie da dagegen?
Ich nehme der Kandikor ein.
Kandikor.
Aha. Und wie viel Milligramm?
Das ist das achten Milligramm, der nehme ich morgens und abends ein.
Mhm, morgens und abends.
Okay.
Außer dann Bullutochtdruck,
haben Sie eine andere Vorerkrankung, ja?
Nee, also, wenn der Husten mal irgendwie unangenehm wird,
dann habe ich auch so ein Medikament,
ich weiß noch gar nicht, wie das heißt,
also da habe ich so Husten tropfen
und das hilft mir eigentlich ganz gut.
Und ja, wie gesagt, dann habe ich auch noch so Tropfen gegen die Verstopfung,
aber sonst muss ich eigentlich nichts einnehmen.
Mhm, ja, wenn Sie Husten haben,
nehmen Sie dagegen Husten tropfen.
Ja, genau.
Das hilft sehr.
Außer dann diese Tropfen, manchmal auch für Metallbeginn.
Ja, genau.
Außer dann nehmen Sie keine weiteren Medikamenten ein.
Die sonst nehme ich nichts ein.
Ja.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Allergie gegen bestimmte Medikamente
oder bestimmte Nahrungsmittel?
Ich wüsste nicht, dass ich gegen irgendwas allergespinnen.
Nee, also ich habe noch nie Probleme.
Na gut, ich nehme auch nicht viele Medikamente,
aber ich habe auch noch nie die Schwierigkeiten gehabt.
Vielleicht Hausausstab oder Laser, Polen.
Nee, also diese ganzen Geschichten, die da habe ich nichts.
Nee.
Okay.
Haben Sie Unfallzreglichkeit gegen zum Beispiel Fruktose, Laktose oder Gluten?
Nein, ich kann eigentlich alles essen, was ich essen will.
Und leben Ihre Eltern noch?
Meine Mutter, die ist früh gestorben.
Die hatte im Alter dann so Zuckerkramkeit
und die hatte auch Großkrebs.
Und daran ist sie beschließlich gestorben.
Ja.
Tut mir leid, sie hatte Zuckerkramkeit und Bundeskrebs.
Richtig.
Ja, genau.
Daran ist sie gestorben.
Ja.
Und mein Vater ist eigentlich relativ gesund, würde ich sagen.
Da ist natürlich auch schon hoch betagt, aber ja, also eigentlich geht es ihm ganz gut.
Ich wüsste nicht, dass er irgendwas hat.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Nein, ich war einzigkündig.
Okay.
Haben Sie schon mal, sind Sie schon mal operiert worden?
Die einzige Operation, die mir jetzt so einfällt,
ich habe mal an dem linken Bein, sind mal die Krampfalarm operiert worden.
Das ist aber auch schon fünf Jahre her.
Linken Beinkrampfalarm.
Okay.
Schon, was haben Sie gesagt?
Seit wann?
Wann haben Sie?
Vor fünf Jahren war das.
Vor fünf Jahren.
Ja, okay.
Und jetzt gucken wir ihre Gewohnheiten.
Wir haben schon über Rauchen gesprochen und trinken sie Alkohol.
Ja, also ich trinke gerne mal ein Glas Rotwein und bei Festen
manchmal muss man da einen Schluck mit trinken.
Ja, und was, was ich bei so Geselligen anlässt,
kann man sich nicht immer ausschließen.
Ja, da trinkt man ein Glas Wein oder ein Glas Sekt oder so was mit.
Ja.
Und wie oft trinken Sie?
Also überwiegend eigentlich so am freien Wochenende.
Ja.
Freien und Wochenende.
Und bitte nehmen Sie nester Frage nicht persönlich.
Das ist eine routine Frage.
Nehmen Sie Drogen ein oder haben Sie schon Kontakt jetzt?
Drogen? Nee, mit Drogen habe ich nichts an den Nehmen.
Okay.
Und jetzt aktören Sie richtig?
Ja, ja.
Okay.
Und jetzt gucken wir ihr soziale Geschichte.
Was sind Sie von der Hochzeit?
Ja, ich sage, ich bin Geschäftsführer einer.
Ja, ja, natürlich.
Ja, natürlich.
Wir haben so viel gesprochen über diese Entschuldigung.
Und sind Sie verheiratet?
Ich bin verheiratet, ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Wir haben drei Kinder, ja.
Und die sind auf alle noch im Haus, ja.
Und sind Ihre Kinder gesund?
Die sind alle gesund, ja, ja.
Perfekt.
Ja, Sie sagten schon, Sie haben viel Stress beim Arbeit.
Ja, ja.
Und dann haben Sie Stress beim Sozialleben?
Na ja, dadurch, dass ich Stress bei der Arbeit habe,
komme ich halt auch spät nach Hause.
Da sind auch nicht immer alle begeistert.
Und dann ist natürlich mit den Kindern,
die wollen dann am Wochenende auch mal Zeit mit mir haben.
Und meine Frau auch.
Und ja, das ist schon auch manchmal stressig.
Verstehe.
Ja, wegen dieser voller Arbeit, Seite.
Ja, und auch weil ich so viel unterwegs bin, ne?
Genau.
Ja, Herr Kölmann, ich bin fertig mit meinen Fragen.
Ich würde gerne jetzt eine kurze Zusammenfassung machen.
Sie haben seit ein paar Tagen im Wadelschmerzen
und Sie haben eine langere Flugreise gehabt.
Und Sie sind immer viele Stunden unterwegs.
Sie sind Geschäftsführer.
Und diese Schmerzen ist immer verschlimmert.
Und Ihre Warteparat hat rote Farbe und geschwollen.
Und Sie haben keine Kompressionsstrumpfe benutzt in dieser Zeit.
Aber Sie sind ja immer so unbequem, Sie sind sehr, ja.
Ja, ich weiß aber, lange Reise, es ist besser für die Flugreise.
Und Sie haben jetzt keine Luftnot und keine Fieber.
Und diese schmerzstrahlende Knie aus und...
Also die Knikele, ne?
Knikele.
Und das ist rechte Seite.
Das sind die beiden, ja.
Und wenn Sie laufen, das tut mehr.
Und außerdem raten Sie seit langerem.
Und laufen ist es schlimmer, aber mit Hochlagerung, es hat besser geworden.
Es ist besser geworden, ja, ein bisschen.
Und das ist die Rückhandeschmatzung.
Und Sie bewertet sechs von einem Skala.
Und Sie haben so lange seit Verstopfung.
Nehmen Sie manchmal Abführmittel dagegen, aber sehr sehr.
Und Sie haben natürlich Schlafprobleme wegen dieser langen Reise und jetlag.
Ja, genau.
Trinken Sie manchmal Wein gegen diese, aber es hat nicht so hilfreich.
Es war nicht so hilfreich, ja.
Genau.
Aber zum Genuss trinke ich schon auch immer mein Glas Wein, ja.
Und Sie haben viel Stress beim Arbeit und Sie haben jetzt aktuell keine Wüsten.
Aber manchmal Trokene Wüsten haben Sie.
Ja, genau.
Und Sie fühlen sich, Sie fühlen Ihre Bewegung immer langsamer als früher.
Aber das ist schon lange, das ist nicht neu.
Ja, ich bin nicht so fit, ja klar.
Ja, ich bin 52, ne?
Nicht so alt, 52.
Sie haben Bluthoff zurück und nehmen Sie dagegen Kandikor, achten sie Gramm.
Ja, und wegen dieser Wüsten manchmal nehmen Sie höchstentropfen ein.
Und außerdem für Schlafene manchmal Tropfen ein.
Sie haben vor fünf Jahren linken Bein wegen Krampfader Operation gehabt.
Und Ihre Mutter hatte Brustkrebs und Zuckerkrankheit.
Und nehmen Sie manchmal Alkohol.
Und Sie sind verheiratet und haben drei Kinder.
Sie haben drei Kinder, ja, das war es.
Und Herr Poviman, haben Sie FK genannt?
Ja, Sie haben jetzt alles manchmal wiederholt.
Ich will jetzt natürlich wissen, wie es weitergeht, weil ich wieder los kann,
was man gegen die Schmerzen machen kann.
Und wie lange ich noch hier bleiben muss, möchte ich das in den Jahren.
Gute Frage.
Erstmal, wir haben nur diese Anamnesisch-Sprecht durchgeführt.
Erstmal, ich würde gerne körperliche Untersuchungen machen.
Danach, ich werde fürs Labor Blut abnehmen.
Und sobald die Ergebnisse ich bekomme, werde ich wieder bei Ihnen sein.
Und wir werden über Ihre Situation besprechen.
Und wie lange müssen Sie hier bleiben?
Jetzt mindestens, glaube ich, zwei, drei Stunden, weil erst mal müssen wir über die Ergebnisse warten.
Ah, also lange dauert das?
Ja, das dauert ein bisschen, mindestens zwei Stunden.
Aber danach werden wir wieder sprechen.
Okay, ja.
Alles klar.
Dankeschön.
Haben Kollegen oder Kolleginnen noch eine Frage?
Ja, ich habe eine Frage.
Ja bitte.
Ist dieser Rötung in Ihrem Unterschenkel scharf begrenzt oder nicht scharf begrenzt?
Scharf begrenzt, würde ich das nicht sagen.
Nein, das ist eigentlich so diffusorot der Unterschenkel.
Das zweite Frage ist, gab es in der letzten Zeit eine Verletzung, Unfall oder Insektenstich?
Nein, also Unfall habe ich nicht gehabt.
Und ich wüsste nicht, dass ich mich verletzt habe und ich war auch ein,
jetzt sind ja keine Insekten mehr draußen.
Also, da, wo ich unterwegs war, war ich auch nur, war ich nicht irgendwie draußen.
Also, ich glaube, Insektenstich kann ich ausschließen.
Zerjuckt auch nicht oder ist nicht so wie so ein Insektenstich.
Okay, dann gehen wir.
Ich habe eine Frage.
Bitte.
Haben Sie Anbetroffenen bei den Pipen oder Cowboys geführt?
Nein, eigentlich nicht, würde ich nicht sagen.
Das tut nur weh.
Ich habe nicht gefragt, ob es für Appetit und Gewicht verletzt, nicht gefragt,
im Füchthard nicht gefragt.
Stimmt, die drei Sachen sind nicht gefragt.
Haben Sie Anbetroffenen bei einer Überwärmung damit?
Ja, da habe ich auch gesagt.
Das ist heiß und rot.
Und geschwollene Beine, Sie haben gesagt nur rechte.
Aber wir müssen fragen, beide geschwollen oder nicht,
weil der Patient hat artillerliche Pärtonie.
Ah ja, okay.
Also, es ist mir nicht aufgefallen, dass beide Beine geschwollen,
sonst die Füße geschwollen sind.
Ja, na gut, nach so einer langen Flugreise sind die Füße natürlich schon ein bisschen dick,
aber normal, alltag sind die Füße nicht geschwollen.
Vielen Dank.
Ja.
Können wir als erstes gesprochen?
Ich hoffe, ja, einen Moment.
Seit wann genau diese Schmessen?
Ich habe das nicht gehört.
Hat es das seit drei Tagen?
Ein paar Tage, wir haben jetzt drei Tage, oder?
Ich wollte sagen drei Tage.
Ja, drei Tage.
Vor vier Tagen ist er wiedergekommen, von der Flugreise,
und nächsten Tag fing das an.
Der Patient hat gesagt, ein paar Tage, wir müssen detailliert, oder?
Ein paar Tage bedeutet auf Deutsch.
Ja, das können zwei oder drei sein, das ist flexibel, würde ich sagen.
Ja, muss man nach Hagen.
Okay, danke schön.
Ja, okay.
Gut.
Okay, ich fange an.
Ja, schönen guten Abend, Herr Oberarztin.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patient aufgenommen.
Heute habe ich einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen.
Ich würde gerne von meinem Patienten erzählen,
haben Sie Zeit, darf ich?
Ja, natürlich, wir haben Sie gesehen, erzählen Sie mir.
Herr Rainer Corviman ist 52 Jahre alt,
20.9.72 geboren.
Er sei 78 cm und wegen...
Ist es 78 cm?
78.
178.
Ja, 1,78 m, oder?
Ja, 178, ja.
Ja, ich würde sagen, 178 cm
und aktuell wiege 88 kg schwer.
Er stellte sich heute wegen seit 3 Tagen bestehende,
dürrückende, unterschiedlich Schmerzen am Rechts-
oder rechter Seite Betroffene, unterschiedlich Schmerzen.
Und als...
Er stellte sich vor.
Seit 2-3 Tagen bestehende,
rechter Seite Betroffene,
dürrückende, unterschiedlich Schmerzen bei uns vor.
Okay, gut.
Er bewertete auf der Skala 6 diese Schmerzen.
Er berichtet,
um die Schmerzen zu erheben.
Er hat sich auf der Skala 6 geschmackt.
Er berichtet uns, dass er eine langere Flugreise gehabt habe.
Gehabt habe, ja.
Gehabt habe.
Und er gab noch an, dass die Schlima,
die Schmerzen immer Schlima geworden seien.
Progredient, hm?
Und die Betroffene Beine hat rote Farbe und geschwollen.
Ist gerötet und geschwollen, ja?
Die Betroffene Beine...
Das betroffenen Bein, ein Bein.
Ja, das betroffenen Bein ist rötet...
Gerötet und geschwollen.
Ha, gerötet und geschwollen.
Mhm.
Gerötet und geschwollen.
Und die Frage nach Disney,
ist, dass die Schmerzen die Schmerzen auf die Kniekehle strahlen.
Gerade die Kniekehle aus, ja.
Die Kniekehle bedeutet direkt,
Rückseite vom Kniegelenk.
Patille.
Ah, Rückseite vom Kniegelenk.
Ja, ich habe verstanden.
Rückseite.
Und er berichtet auch, dass die Schmerzen beim Laufen verschlimmert
und beim Hochlagerung besser geworden.
Mhm.
Und die vegetative Namnese war unauffällig, bis auf Obstipation
Disney und Disney.
Mhm.
Und, ja, und er...
er... ja, er...
er...
ähm...
mh, okay.
Erstmal.
Er habe sich stress beim Arbeiten.
Ja?
Er hat viel Stress, ja.
Und das hat er noch?
Ich habe diese Analyse ein bisschen kopiziert gemacht
und, ja, ich versuche ein bisschen...
Okay.
Er leid, er war vor Erkrankungen.
Ich habe den Atelier der Hipatone seit 15 Jahren, dagegen nehme er Kandiko 8 Milligramm,
einmal morgens, einmal abends.
Und außerdem habe er trockene Hüsten und er stammt nach vor fünf Jahren linken Bein,
weil die Kurs ist Operation, war Ritz in Operation, ja.
Und die Allergien seien bei ihm nicht bekannt und die Familienanamnese ergab,
und die Diabetes mellitus bei der Mutter.
Und er ist seit 30 Jahren ein Schachterl segelich, das macht 30 Packiers.
Und er trinkt nur Feiern und Wochenende ein Glas Kotwein oder Wein.
Und die Frage nach Drogen wurde verneint.
Er sei Geschäftsmann von Behof.
Er ist verheiratet und habe drei Kinder.
Er habe viel Streit beim Arbeit.
Bei der Arbeit, ja.
Und ja, das war es.
Gut, was ist ja jetzt Ihre Vermutung?
Die Klinik und die Mal sind am ersten auf,
TfH TfWT.
Was machen Sie diagnostisch mit den Patienten?
Diagnostisch, ja.
Ja, erst mal beim Urtrechalluntersuchung.
Ja, erst mal gucken Sie den Patienten noch an, oder?
Ja, erst mal körperliche Untersuchungen.
Ja, und worauf hatten Sie bei der körperlichen Untersuchung das Patient?
Mhm.
Patient sagt ja schon, der Unterschenkerbereich ist geschwollen und warm.
Ich kontrolliere diesen Bereich und ich vergleiche die mit anderen.
Und vielleicht diese Trombose geht lunggen oder in den anderen Körperbereich.
Ich kontrolliere Patienten Luftnot oder andere Beschwerden.
Also Sie horchen ihn ab auf die Lunge, Herz und Lunge horchen sie ab?
Ja, sie kautzutieren.
Genau, genau.
Patient sagte er habe keine Luftnot, aber für Sicherheit ist die Situation besser.
Prüfen Sie das.
Dann mache ich Blutabnahme und ein Wort, der Daimersch.
Der Dimmer.
Der Dimmer ist sehr wichtig.
Und sehr viel, die andere Entschließungsparameter kann ich kontrollieren.
Und danach Bein Ultraschall-Untersuchung.
Ja.
Doppelersch.
Du hast noch auf ihn, ja, genau.
Mhm.
Ja.
Was wäre denn differential diagnostisch auch noch möglich?
Differential diagnostisch vielleicht per A4k.
Das wäre eine Möglichkeit, ja.
Wegen dieser Beinschmack.
Was wäre sonst noch möglich?
Außerdem vielleicht Nieseninsuffizienz oder…
Okay, denken Sie mal, ein Kollege hat gefragt,
Stich instiftiert.
Lass uns ein Säckchen stich oder Verletzung.
Ja, die beide ist mehr logisch.
Mhm.
Genau.
Nein, aber worauf, was wäre denn da differential, die Erdnossestan?
Zum Beispiel Borreliosa oder…
Nee.
Falsche Richtung.
Er hat zwei Sachen gefragt.
Ist die Rötung abgegrenzt?
Ja.
Und er hat gefragt, gibt es eine Verletzung oder ein Insektenstich?
So, was wollte er ausschließen?
Hm.
Er wollte Insektenstich ausschließen und wenn die besten waren…
Nee, er will etwas anderes ausschließen.
Hm.
Was?
Er will ein Erisipel ausschließen.
Ah, ja, Erisipel.
Das wäre eine denkbare Differentialdiagnose.
Ja, wenn jemand mit einem dicken roten heißen Bein kommt,
muss man gucken, checken, ob der ein Erisipel hat.
Deswegen ist es nungswärtig, ist natürlich richtig, ja.
Hm.
Aber man muss natürlich diese Differentialdiagnose einkalkulieren.
Und was wäre noch eine denkbare Differentialdiagnose?
Der hat ja angegeben, es tut ihm in der Kniekehle weh.
Ach, Schuße, aber ohne Rötung.
Hm.
Schwellung, Kniekehle, Schmerzen, Bäckerzüste.
Ja, ja.
Gut.
Aber Sie sind ja auf der richtigen Spur mit der Trobose gut.
Also Sie machen Ultraschall und was erwarten Sie bei den Laborwerten?
Laborwerten vielleicht für Teffateu.
Ja?
Ja, der Darmisch kann mehr hoch sein.
Ja, dann kann man sich ja eigentlich sagen, ne?
Genau.
Ja.
Gut, was wäre denn die Therapie, wenn der Patient tatsächlich eine Trombose hat?
Antitrombotisch Medikamente oder Heparin.
Ja, und?
Was noch?
Sie haben ihn gefragt, ob er Kompressor schon vergetragen hat unterwegs.
Hm.
Ja.
Äh, ist aber ich dachte als Medikamentöser oder?
Ganzem.
Was muss er denn jetzt machen, wenn er die Trombose hat?
Hm.
Ähm, ja, diese Kompressionsstrumphe.
Aber jetzt können wir...
Ja, ich muss ja jetzt tragen.
Klar, ja.
Also wenn er die Trombose hat, braucht er Anticoagulation und er braucht, ähm,
er braucht eine Kompression.
So.
Und wenn er keine Strumpfe mehr zu Hause hat fürs Rechtebein, dann muss man ihm das
Bein erst mal wickeln.
Hm.
Also er braucht eine Kompression und er braucht, wie lange musst ihr denn, äh,
eine Glutverdünnung kriegen?
Ähm, ich weiß es nicht genau, aber ich vermute 5 Tage im Bestens.
Hm.
Okay, und dann?
Dann, ähm, die, ähm, also ich, ich erinnere zwei Möglichkeiten für drei Wochen
und für erste 5 Tage vielleicht.
Hm.
Halbes Jahr.
Halbes Jahr, Glutverde, also Glutverde und halbes Jahr, also Makumna
und halbes Jahr Kompression und vorabsetzen, vorabsetzen,
äh, Ultraschallkontrolle.
Hm.
Okay.
Juh.
Ähm, ja, halten Sie mich auf dem Laufenden, was mit Herrn Hovermann ist, ob sich das bestätigt
mit den Trombose, mit der Trombose.
Nö?
Okay.
Ja.
Gut.
So.
Ähm, Sie haben gemerkt, das ist ein großer Unterschied zwischen den beiden
Abschnitten.
Ja.
Sprachlich waren Sie ziemlich sicher in der Anamnese.
Da waren Sie allerdings, ähm, ein bisschen unsortiert.
Ja.
Sie sind nicht streng nach Ihrem Bogen vorgegangen.
Und, ähm, es hat Sie versehrt.
Mhm.
Dass der Patient Ihnen, äh, praktisch an der falschen Stelle schon
Informationen gegeben hat, die Sie da noch gar nicht haben wollten.
Ja.
Die haben Sie aber, ähm, dann hinterher noch mal gefragt,
was natürlich nicht so gut ankommt, wenn Sie das vorher schon mal gefragt
haben oder eigentlich schon die, die Informationen bekommen haben.
Und Sie fragen dann noch mal nach.
Mhm.
Ähm, also das ist schon, das ist schon gut, seinen strukturierten
Fragebogen zu haben im Kopf und zu wissen, was frage ich an welcher
Stelle.
Aber man muss dann schon auch so flexibel sein.
Und die Punkte, die man bereits beantwortet bekommen hat,
dann zumindest zu notieren, dass man das mit drin hat.
Ja.
Gut, das ist die Sache.
Ähm, was mir aufgefallen ist, ähm, dass Sie, dass Sie diese
klassischen Satzbau, ähm, Vertrehung machen.
Äh, dann ich werde.
Ja.
Dann ich werde das und das machen.
Ähm, dann werde ich.
An zweiter Stelle kommt das Verb.
So.
Und dann ähm, sobald die Ergebnisse ich bekomme.
Mhm.
Sobald ich die Ergebnisse bekomme.
Ja.
Nebensatz fängt an Verb ist hinten, so wie ein erster,
in zweiter Stelle.
Ja.
Also, sobald ich die Ergebnisse bekomme, sage ich Ihnen Bescheid,
wie es weitergeht.
Ja.
Das, und diese, diese Konstruktion, dann ich werde, das haben Sie
mehrfach gemacht.
Einmal habe ich es während der Fahrt korrigiert.
Aber achten Sie ein bisschen drauf, dass Sie eine richtige
Satzstellung machen.
Mhm.
Ne?
Ähm, können Sie wiederholen, was haben Sie gesagt, sobald ich?
Sie haben gesagt, sobald die Ergebnisse ich bekomme.
Mhm.
Ja, aber es heißt, sobald ich die Ergebnisse bekomme,
gebe ich Ihnen Bescheid.
Mhm.
Ja, verstanden.
Ja.
Gut.
Ähm, das war diese Geschichte.
Ja, ja, also die, die Präsentation nachher war
wirklich ein bisschen durcheinander, muss ich sagen.
Vielleicht habe ich sie durcheinander gemacht,
weil ich sie gleich am Anfang unter Wochen habe.
Ja.
Aber es kam, es kam unsortiert.
Sie haben ja eigentlich sortiert gefragt, dann berichten sie
doch auch genauso schön sortiert.
Ja, das, das hat ja alles seinen bestimmten Platz in der,
in der Wiedergabe.
Jeder, also das, das ist eigentlich ja in jedem,
in jedem Ananesigesprich gleich, dass man eine bestimmte
Struktur hat, dass man erst nach dem Personal,
die ihn fragt, dann nach den Beschwerden, dann kommt die
vegetative Anamnese, ach, das ist auch wieder so was.
Wenn eine vegetative Anamnese trocknen mussten,
äh, Quatsch, ähm, Schlafs, Schlafstörung,
Obstipation hat, ist sie eigentlich nicht mehr
unauffällig, sondern dann hat sie ja zwei
Ausführlichkeiten.
Ja, so, ähm, dann, was sie nicht ausdrücklich gesagt haben,
dass diese Punkte wie äh, Nachtweiß, ähm,
Herzrasen, ähm, Gewichtsverlust verneint wurden.
Das gehört ja auch dazu, auf Nachfrage wurden
diese Punkte verneint.
Muss man auch sagen.
Gut.
Ja, was mir aufgefallen ist, dass sie nicht so gerne
die Fachbegriffe benutzen.
Was, was ich Schlafstörung, Insomnia, ähm,
bei irgendwas ist es mir noch aufgefallen.
Ähm, ja, also, das, das ist im,
Rubot, Colour, Ödemme.
Bitte?
Ja, genau, da, da ist es mir aufgefallen, genau.
Äh, dass sie gesagt haben, das, das Bein ist gerötet,
ist rot. Ja, oder er beschreibt ein gerötetes Bein.
Also, nee, da muss man schon sagen, ne,
Rubor, genau, Rubor, Tumor, Dolor, ja,
das sind Schwellungen, ja, das sind die
Entzündungszeichen, das wäre schon gut,
wenn sie da eben die Fachbegriffe benutzen.
Ja.
Jut!
Ja, und bei der Therapie der Thrombose
waren die natürlich auch nicht so ganz sicher.
Ähm, ja, ja, Eresipel, ne,
also da hat eigentlich ihr Kollege
ihnen eine dicke fette Fährte gelegt,
dass man das zymerazal Diagnose
auf alle Fälle abstragen muss, ja.
Eresipel zeichnet aus durch die scharf abgegrenzte
Rötung, natürlich auch durch Fieberkramkeitsgefühl
und eben potenzielle Eintrittsstelle,
Verletzung, Insektenstich, ne, das sind die,
das sind die Punkte.
Gut, ja, und sie waren eigentlich auch nicht so
ganz engagiert, was die, was die
körperliche Untersuchung angeht, ja.
Es gibt ja klassische Thrombosezeichen,
haben sie nicht erwähnt, ja.
Sie wollten gleich gerne das Ultraschallbild machen.
Ja, das ist ja auch richtig, das ist ja die
aktuelle Methode, aber die klassischen Zeichen
macht man eigentlich trotzdem noch, ne.
Man macht Paya-Homan, Meierzeichen,
Fantastide-Pyrithéan-Pulse, ja.
Das sind die, die Klassiker,
wenn sie die körperliche Untersuchung
erst mal beschreiben, ne.
Abgesehen von dem, was sie in Augen scheinen nehmen,
dass sie sagen, ich gucke nach Rötung,
Schwellung und Taste, was, was ich,
Eindrückbarkeit der Ideen oder sowas,
hm.
Gut.
Also, die Thrombose ist nicht ihr Ding,
kann man so sagen, aber die Ananasie war
viel besser, ja.
Die Ananasie war viel besser, da waren sie
eigentlich auch schön zugewandt, haben den
Patienten namentlich angesprochen, das hat mir
gut gefallen.
Aber sie, sie müssen ihren Vortrag
wirklich besser sortieren,
ja.
Und, ja, sie, so die, die Klassiker
der Untersuchung, das wäre schön, wenn sie
da noch ein bisschen zugeben, ne.
Ja, ich möchte auch auf etwas sagen,
Sie haben es gesagt, aber ich möchte es
wiederholen für die, unsere Kollegen.
Die Zusammenfassung sollte nur
aktuelle Hauptbeschwerden umfassen.
Ach, ja, das war auffällig, das war auffällig,
dass sie die ganzen, praktisch die ganze
Ananasie noch einmal den Patienten
vorgelesen haben, ja.
Und der weiß ja, was er ihnen gesagt hat.
Genau, genau, der weiß,
er, was er ihnen gesagt hat.
Genau, da müsste man eigentlich nur, nur sagen,
rechtes Bein ist richtig, ja,
Schwellung seit drei Tagen, Rötung,
Schmerzen, das ist das, was sie zu uns
führt und keine Herzbeschwerden,
keine Atemnot.
So, und jetzt gucken wir weiter, was haben
Sie noch für Fragen, ne.
Aber nicht den ganzen Kram von den Eltern,
von der Familien-Situation,
das, was ich, das will man alles
eigentlich als Patient dann auch nicht nochmal hören.
Der Typ, der war ja auch so ein bisschen
stressig, ja, der hat ja gesagt, auf die Uhr
er will weg und wie lange muss ich denn
jetzt noch warten?
So jemand reagiert natürlich sauer,
wenn sie dem nochmal die ganze Geschichte
erzählen, dann machen Sie doch mal hin, ja,
ich will doch weg, ne,
muss doch mal jetzt zügig vorwärtsgehen.
Gut, aber ich glaube auch, also ich wüsste nicht,
dass das in irgendeinem Prüfungssystem
verlangt würde, dass man den ganzen Kram
erzählen.
Ja, für den FSB-Pilfung haben,
müssten wir eine klare
Aufklärung machen.
Das schon, ja.
Patientaufklärung.
Anderenfalls haben wir keine
Seite für die Information und Patientenaufklärung.
Deswegen müssen wir kurz seit
eine Zusammenfassung.
Genau, also kurze Zusammenfassung
und dann weiteres Prozede erklären.
Genau.
Gut.
Vielleicht haben wir noch eine Gelegenheit nochmal
eine andere Analyse zusammen zu machen.
Wer vielleicht ganz gut, ne?
Ich denke gut.
Haben Kollegen noch andere Fragen
für die Simulation?
Keine.
Keine weiteren Kommentare.
Wir sehen uns übermorgen.
Ja, wir...